we just heard from Carolyn Flint there
clearly emotional she said she's trying
to stand back her anger she said that
those around Corbin had been off the
planet in the way that they have ignored
some of the concerns of working-class
constituents in her seat she was saying
that some in the shadow cabinet look
down on her voters are stupid that labor
may never win again unless there's
change what did she make some of the
point she made when I only saw the end
of her interview is important that we
listen to Caroline I'm desperately sorry
that Don Valley has lost such a powerful
voice empowerment it's right that we
listen to what Caroline says I too have
represented a leave constituency it
doesn't get more working-class than East
Leeds that were voted by over 60% to
leave I won that election and we got a
bigger labor vote than we did in either
mm I'm not saying that I'm saying what
it shows that we can win in leave seats
the picture is complicated Caroline who
I respect greatly actually voted for
Boris Johnson's deal and still didn't
win think what that shows is that
there's no easy answers to the problem
we've had in this really bad and
heartbreaking elections or but it is
important that we listen to Caroline and
all of the colleagues bose colleagues
who lost their seats but also people who
wanted elected as new MPs who suddenly
weren't elected on Thursday either I
mean it was a bloodbath wasn't it what
happened this week labor want fewer
seats that in any election since 1935
Jeremy Corbyn lost to half a million
voters compared to the last election
what do you think went wrong well it was
a dreadful election results and there's
no getting away from that there's no
prettifying that I think it became as
per the sky a headline or the sky line
the breads its election if you look at
2017 and compare it 2019 in 2017 we had
the same leader the same shadow
chancellor the same shadow home
secretary a very similar socialist
manifesto and we gained 3 million votes
fast forward to 29
and we had a bad election defeats and
lost votes and lost seats the thing that
changed between those two years in my
opinion is that brexit became something
which overshadowed traditional party
loyalty that's the point isn't it
brexit was the defining issue today and
people did not like Labor's position on
bricks that I mean that's exactly what
Caroline Flynn is saying but in these
seats people just didn't like what you
were saying I mean our attempt to bring
the country together people who were to
leave and remain didn't work well it did
bring the country together against your
exit position
I accept that didn't work I'm so sorry
and the Labor Party's so sorry that
didn't work is repeal in our country
they were going to be facing tough
tougher times and next five years
through no fault of their own under
attacked rioting number 10 Downing
Street Boris Johnson but this was a
briggsie election I don't believe the
next election will be drags it's
election and what is the case is that
there's no electoral future of the Labor
Party
if we water down our opposition to the
conservative cuts and conservative
austerity
that's on the way in the next few years
okay boss Johnson says instructions are
you but doesn't he prioritize NHS I
don't believe a single thing that Boris
Johnson says he's showing us say
anything in order to get into power and
I think that this talk about the NHS and
legislation but in their commitments
legislation is a simple gimmick let's
see what he does on breaks it just
quickly was it a mistake to support a
second referendum in retrospect well I
think the issue begs is now doing just
about leaving European you have to
analyze it and it's just days after the
election so a straight answer would be
fine do you think it was a mistake
genuinely do you think I think it was
right to try and bring people together
and let the people have a final say the
people now rejected that and we need to
move on from that
we're leaving the European Union what we
now need to look at is trying to when we
leave protect jobs protect the economy
and stop any sell out about NHS to
trumps back up do you think it was right
then to have a second referendum I think
he was right to attempt to bring the
country together on that basis did it
fail we've got to be open it did fail
we've got to understand that the place
where I mean he was complex picture
across the country but the place is
where we did worst was small northern
leave towns where we lost votes the
Conservative Party and lost votes the
bread
party we needs the Labour Party to get
the votes back of people who voted leave
and who were persuaded by the
conservative slogan get beggars it done
they did want to get Briggs it done okay
and Jeremy Corbyn has written in two
newspapers today welcome to have a quick
look at what he said in the observer
this is our Jeremy Court and he said I'm
proud that on austerity on corporate
power on inequality and on the climate
emergency we've won the arguments and
rewritten the terms of political debate
but I regret that we did not succeed in
converting that into a parliamentary
majority for change if this is winning
the argument what is losing the argument
it like well I think that in terms of
winning the argument it's telling that
Boris Johnson felt it necessary to make
pledges about properly funding on us he
felt it necessary to say that austerity
was going to be over I don't think it
will be unfortunately but it's a tragedy
that we didn't win this general election
it's a tragedy I mean when I was out
campaigning American city and elsewhere
I met people suffering to a desperate
for labor government people on universal
credits people paying the bedroom tax
people on zeros contracts and we've see
the demonization of migrants as well by
Boris Johnson all of these people's
lives would be worse off because labour
didn't win that election for that I'm
truly heartbroken we need to win the
next general election and that means
winning back those lost votes and it
particularly means winning back the
votes of people who wanted to leave the
European Union you're talking about
winning back votes in different areas
you can just show two maps here which I
think kind of illustrates this point
really so the one on the left is from
1997 so you can see the kind of spread
of red there in 2019
it's almost as he retreated into these
metropolitan areas and abandoned horse
ways in the country I mean do you think
you really understand your kind of
voters in these Hartman's
well as I say I represent a
working-class leave seat Leeds is a
metropolitan area that wasn't it I mean
my my constituency is very working-class
area that voted by over 60% to leave the
European Union and as I say we got to a
bigger labor belt there than we did in
2001 2005 and 2000 to be learned it was
a disastrous a
election results and for that we're
truly sorry but I think as I said this
was a Beggs election the next election
won't be a basic election but we need to
look at ourselves and our performance
and how we lost votes with humility we
need to analyze that just Towson what
was the biggest mistake then if you have
to look at it with humility you need to
analyze what do you think was the
biggest mistake that the Labour Party
meant not external forces not the media
not brexit what was your biggest mistake
I think we do need further time to
analyze ups we lost votes of different
areas in different areas but in
different areas we lost votes of
different parties but I think the
biggest mistake that either party made
was perhaps under estimating the desire
for people who voted leave to leave the
your opinion you still think my friend
was a right policy I think he's right to
try and bring people together and it's
very easy in hindsight to say but look
there are no easy solutions some people
were in our party was saying the easiest
solution would have been to become an
ultra main party we didn't look what
happened to the Liberal Democrats their
leader wasn't even elected and they
pursued ultra remain position ok and
when we went out during the election
campaign whether he's run pressure
Grimsby Kensington Cheltenham something
that came up again and again was Jeremy
Corbyn was Jamie Corbin's leadership a
problem Jeremy Corbyn was mentioned on
the doorstep with me and I'm a great
admirer and friend of Jeremy what do
people say but when I was campaigning
for Tony Blair Gordon Brown there
Miliband they were mentioned on the
doorstep to what do people say about
Jeremy Corbyn on the doorstep - well a
minority people mentioned what the dread
in the Sun or the Daily Mail and I think
there was a character assassination of
Jeremy Corbyn by what is something daily
what was the concerns the concerns were
of the kind of were basically repeating
headlines that had the Sun and Ayla met
a very effectively puts across what were
the concerns well you read the Sun in
the Daily Mail as much as I have
conversations you've had what what
people change of course you can't just
it just it sometimes I just feel like
you know Caroline Flint's there saying
about how boaters have been treated as
stupid you're effectively saying that
anyone with concerns
Jeremy Corbyn was been duped by a
headline no I'm not I'm not saying that
why don't you just say what that
concerns were that because for example
people were saying things that such as
you know oh he's like a terrorist or a
racist whether both of things which is
completely untrue but were pushed by the
right concerns over allegations of
anti-semitism in the way that was dealt
with in the party I'm guessing the
racism part the terrorism stuff I
supposes things like saying and that
it's better to arrest terrorists
overseas or to bring back Islamic state
fighters to the United Kingdom to allow
them to have citizenship to not have
their citizenship revoked
I mean you previous associations
meetings with people like I array
sympathizers things like saying that her
masks or friends or allies I mean these
are the kind of thing this isn't it that
people were concerned about you can
argue that they were wrong but that
there was other sides of the story that
the headlines were overwritten but they
are genuine concerns people felt know
some people did feel those concerns of
course and it's been talked about a lot
but at the same time we need to look at
the fact Inc and I'm not pretending this
election result was anything other than
bad and bad for the people represent and
seek to represent but we did get more
Labor votes we did for example in the
2010 general election the product not
less seats yes the population has gone
up since then but the problem is the
distribution of those votes so we got
more votes and one with one under Tony
Blair in the past however it's affected
he won in the first place though however
his landslide victory however it's a
distribution of those votes and that's
why we need to analyze very careful
because you can pile up votes in certain
seats and it can make no difference
under our system to the outcome that we
get so I think we need to listen we need
to listen to colleagues who lost their
seats we need to listen to colleagues
who we hope to be elected for the first
time but weren't last night I had a
meeting two excellent candidates one
from peniston's Oxbridge one from LA the
valet both seats in South Yorkshire that
voted leave that we hope to win and
didn't and obviously very carefully to
what they had to say and it's important
the party listens and reflects because
if we don't we're not going to be able
to win the next general election I
believe we can win the next general
election and I believe that we will
you gonna run for the leadership in
terms of the question of leadership
obviously there's people talking to
their family there's people talking to
their colleagues I've made no secret the
fact that I would like to see Rebecca
lung Bailey as leader of the Labour
class that saddest ition for her to make
her black see Rebecca on Bailey's early
delay particle think she understands
northern leave seats she's had
experience in the shadow cabinet in
charge of the shadow Bay's departments
and I think she's somebody who could
really help us to win back those votes
that we lost but of course that's a
decision for her that's why I would like
to see happen deputation be a fantastic
first woman leader of the Labour Party
would you like to run as head acti
well I'm considering that colleagues
have approached me about that and
grassroots members and trade units
encouraged me to stand I'll be
considering that in the coming weeks but
what I'm focused on at the moment is
trying to analyze exactly what went
wrong in this general action exactly
what we can do to make it go right
because obviously I understand the
question of Legion typically it is very
interesting to people but the people
aren't thinking of most the people I met
on the doorstep in my constituency and
across the country who needed a Labour
government and it breaks my heart to
think that we didn't win that general
election because they are going to pay
the price for that we've got a lot of
work to do and we need to start that
work straight away just all we've got
you got to ask
this is cropped off on Twitter at Bergen
the grassroots campaign to elect Richard
Bergen as the next leader at the Labour
Party DM for inquiries is it what's been
physics what if you've got only to do
with this well I'm not I haven't had a
look at this Twitter's a funny place
Twitter is Twitter well that's okay but
the point I'd make is need to focus
seriously on those who are missing out
because they're not getting a Labour
government people on universal credit
people paying the bedroom tax people on
zeros contracts people subjected to
those terrible fitness to work
assessments their lives could have
started to get a whole lot better if we
warned that general action we've got a
duty to listen we've got a duty to win I
believe we can win the next general
election when it's not a budget election
okay which about
thank you very much for coming in the
studio thank you